on va aller chercher une réaction à ce
reportage on reçoit tout de suite en
entrevue safieh nolin et auteure
compositrice interprète méconnu bonjour
madame nolin bonjour d'abord votre
première réaction le quand vous avez
pris acte justement de ces chiffres-là
de la place des femmes qui progresse pas
toujours même dans certains festivals on
présume que ça recule quelle est votre
réaction
mais ce serait quand même un brin
décevant qui ajoute que des preuves
comme quoi des gracques sont séparés
pouces par seconde avec mais je crois
que comme un phénomène de société ou
être que tu parle d'un truc religion et
en parents sont concernés puis après un
bout de temps pense à autre chose je
pense qu'on avait quand même un exemple
le dessus je pense que les gens ont
trouvé ce d'ici là à recevoir comme un
patient atteint de trois heures mais qui
est quand même un peu eu beaucoup
d'améliorations à ce niveau là ce serait
dommage vous même avez vous ressenti cet
effet l'un d'eux d'avoir moins de chance
d'avoir moins de classes d'avoir à
lutter plus fort parce que vous êtes une
femme pour faire votre place dans les
festivals mais en fait je pense que moi
personnellement mon expérience comme
compliquée à avoir parce que moi comme
je suis à mon deuxième album fait
naturellement
puis comme la saveur du mois donc j'ai
moins de spectacle par contre ce que ç'a
eu comme impact celle de l'observation
110 kg à chaque fois je me sois festival
je compte un peu les programmations hors
garantie que les autres spectacles des
filles qu'elles saignent son parc à
l'heure qui timide l'avancé puis j'avoue
qu'il ya pas beaucoup de festivals où
j'ai fait j'en aussi qu il ya quand même
beaucoup de femmes à la vente comme
juste comme le jansénisme il faut qu'on
parle de ce billet j'ai vu que le coup
de coeur francophone avait sorti des
têtes d'affiché comme lui tout ayda
field où je sais pas j'ai pas tous
conviés mais c'est 100% masculin ça qu
on n'est pas ici dans une localité du
tout le nom on est loin de la parité
c'est certain est ce que vous voyez des
raisons comment vous l'expliquez vous
ben je pense que en fait les gens se
sont dit on va faire des efforts mais je
pense qu'on peut libre
si pour le faire je crois qu'on écoles
malheureusement la musique est vraiment
jean rumeau c'est quelque chose que je
trouve difficile dans ma carrière de
sans dire que pour ça c'est une personne
que la musique de filles quand la map
est la musique agit pas de genre ni sexe
identité fixe je pense que yo soy je
pense que les gens ont peur de deux
programmes et des filles de l'une des
chansons les filles parce qu'ils ont
peur que la foule suivent peu parce que
la société pas rendu là mais c'est en
faisant des moves avant que tu changes
les gens au fait comment que ça marche
vous vous le vivez aussi un petit peu de
l'intérieur parce que vous êtes sur un
ca d'un festival le festival bleu bleu
de carleton c'est géré par des femmes je
pense dans celles qui sont à la tête de
sa est ce que ça change quelque chose
ben oui parce que c'est comme un truc et
comme qu'il a foutu réfléchisse en amont
et sur ce que réalise beaucoup en étant
dans un style je me rends compte que
c'était quand même plus complexe que ça
en avait l'air tout de juste vous
rappeler des festivals
mettez plus de filles forcez-vous c'est
vraiment plus ce que c'est faux que tu
déploies comme de l'énergie faut que tu
fasses des recherches ou qui traînent
d'avancé moi j'étais sûr que le problème
si nous on n'a pas la parité non le
prisme note que c'était vraiment quelque
chose d'important pour nous si je pense
que le problème c'est que quand tu
essayes de sortir des sentiers battus
je trouve des solutions mais si tu
restes dans la piste qui est déjà fait
c'est vraiment plus difficile je crois
que je vais pas porter d'accusation puis
je pense pas que j'aie la vérité est
juste mais je pense que les gens ont
peur de sortir des sentiers battus il ya
des gens qui disent faudrait peut-être
l'imposé d'une certaine manière avec
toutes sortes de mécanismes nord au
moins un début de parité ce soit par les
subventions qui serait liens sont ou
d'autres façons sont aussi à quel point
cette question là elle
vise vous vous positionnez comme ans sur
cette question de bain c'est vraiment
une question qui devra répondre moi et
scintille manche pour ce même si je
trouve ça dommage mais je crois qu'on
est obligé de forcer un peu les choses
parce que sinon ça va prendre de shamil
en avons la parité typiquement ici on
attend que naturellement ça arrive on
leur peau vraiment parce que on est
tellement dans une société qui comme
difficile pour les femmes qui pour une
invitée que je pense pas que on va
atteindre le coup rapide et à ceux qui
disent parce qu'il y en a que l'écouté
il ya moins de femmes dans les festivals
tout simplement parce que je ne parais
sont moins nombreux jeux plus en plus
beaux peut-être parce que généralement
ils sont un peu moins bonne vous
répondez quoi moi pouvais j'aimerais
vraiment passé quelque peu déçu parce
que je sais pas comment je réagirais je
vous souhaite vraiment insultant parce
que c'est vrai que même un humour dans
tout qui est le leur prophète dans tout
ce qui l'a dit en général les gens on se
trouve en argument là que les femmes
sont moins bonnes moi je trouve que
c'est complètement fou pour que
justement c'est important de mettre des
femmes tourné dans les positions genre
de pouvoir donner lundi en tête
d'affiche parce que ça donne l'exemple à
d'autres femmes ne pouvoir se donner le
pouvoir de le faire c'est juste qu'on
soit le montant finalement c'est juste
que je souhaite maintenant à la merci
beaucoup pour cette entrevue